des soldats français déployés au rwanda
en plein génocide autorisée par l'onu
l'opération turquoise avait un mandat
humanitaire et pourtant rarement une
telle intervention n'a fait autant
produit très tôt le président rwandais
paul kagame accuse la france d'avoir
soutenu et armé le pouvoir génocidaires
hutus 25 ans plus tard de plus en plus
de voix françaises se joignent aux
critiques y compris des militaires comme
le lieutenant colonel guillaume ancel en
1994 il fait partie de ces soldats
français envoyés au rwanda pour
l'opération turquoise
selon lui la vraie nature de la mission
au départ n'est pas humanitaire jusqu'au
1er juillet la seule mission de
l'opération turquoise
c'est d'empêcher les ennemis des
génocidaires d'avancé donc on protège de
fait les génocidaires une description
des événements que réfute cependant
hubert védrine ancien bras droit du
président français françois mitterrand
fait des accusations qui me semble
complètement sortis de leur contexte
c'est des militaires de rang modeste qui
n'avaient pas de vision d'ensemble de ce
qui se passait qui règlent des comptes
etc lors hiérarchie mais les reproches
des geeks et au moins celles ne s'arrête
pas là ce qu'on a fait nous armées
françaises pendant l'opération turquoise
ces deux fêtes soutenir les génocidaires
on n'a jamais participé aux émissions
mais ce qu'on a fait c'est les protéger
et les réarmer
- chez assister dans la deuxième
quinzaine de juillet à livraisons
d'armes des armes livrées aux
génocidaires en totale violation de
l'embargo des avions français avec des
avions de l'armée française de voile
fera dauchy dit en avoir été témoin à
plusieurs reprises en 1994 il était
gestionnaire de la croix rouge française
à goma les arts où j'ai vu les caisses
les caisses c
c'est des caisses et des armes légères
je comprends assez vite que s'est livré
au pouvoir hutu par action c'est de dire
si je comprends bien ce que j'ai sous
les yeux
c'est un énorme scandale une implication
de la france que rejette en bloc
hubert védrine il ya eu un embargo très
tôt en avril
en revanche l'afrique brouillent de
trafiquants c'était rempli de gens y
compris des trafiquants français hubert
védrine dit avoir la conscience
tranquille et il défend avec force le
président mitterrand dont la seule
volonté dit il était d'éviter le
massacre
oui la france a échoué c'est un pompier
qui a échoué pompier volontaire cours je
cours en jeu lesquels jouer mais on peut
pas faire porter aux pompiers
volontaires qu'elle jouait la
responsabilité d'un incendie beaucoup
ici demande depuis longtemps
l'ouverture des archives nationales pour
permettre d'éclaircir le rôle de la
france au rwanda promise par le
président m'a cran une commission
denquête composé d'historiens pourrait
être un premier pas en ce sens mais de
toute évidence même 25 ans après le
génocide
la question continue d'être très
sensible ici jean françois bélanger
radio-canada paris